Ian come on let's pick it up in Lacroix
did you clean the top clean the top Ian
hurry no wash it with the water and
paper towel it down in the crevices my
emergencies are on the end all right
baby let's ride okay so it's pretty big
but with a skilled driver I think he
Andy ready
keep an eye don't be on your phone Abed
this is life and death here we go
it's up to ten it's up to ten oh we get
a little wobbly
[Laughter]
yeah that's delivering mail in style
can you try to make a delivery let's see
okay great we're gonna get it we're
gonna make a mail delivery here in the
Gatsby ripping fast till not wasting any
time I'm delivering the mail yeah I love
that first ever thank you so much you
could yeah do your you could finish your
road
[Laughter]
[Music]
pardon me good
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the Gatsby [ __ ] rules whoa Johnny it
was out let's assess the damage shall we
let's see I mean we did some clean I
mean but overall I think we're in pretty
good shape considering we took something
really took it pretty bad but this
thing's still running like a beauty I
think we're in good shape I mean overall
considering the did we [ __ ] our dork not
really not really guys I think that was
a clean think that's good I think that
GATS I think we're in
I need to get out of the way
well better it hits you welcome
everybody
yes well welcome one and all to the h3
podcast Gatsby experience it has been a
long time coming my friends but this
sweet dream ride has arrived and I think
it's safe to say that nothing will ever
be the same I can on this on this hair
show thank you to Netflix for sponsoring
us today bill burrs new comedy special
paper tiger is available to day just
came out today September 10th on Netflix
available for streaming now also thank
you to stitch fix for sponsoring us now
as you may notice ela is not with me
right now frankly we had a a bad fight
yesterday and frankly I just it was
really it was the worst fight we've ever
had and I don't really want to get too
much into that I don't want to alarm
anybody I can talk more about it later
but I just I don't want to spoil this
beautiful moment that we had with the
Gatsby which has finally graced us and
it's been just been such a pleasure it's
been such a joy and I just look forward
to all the goofs ahead with the Gatsby
so Dan what the [ __ ] Dan's trying to
take the Gatsby up Dan you could just
leave it there what's going on oh he
can't close the door okay Dan's trying
to take the gas back he's not a skilled
skilled of a of a driver as yours truly
all right Dan has successfully cleared
the door you almost took out the cameras
I almost took out the cameras there the
funny thing about the Gatsby is that
we're gonna highlight the features next
week because we have a guest on Friday
but we're gonna we're gonna show you all
the featuring ago the close-up
we're gonna show you the Gatsby X with
the pneumatic wheels we're talking about
up to 10 miles per hour but that thing
feels like it rips way harder than that
we're gonna show you what this thing is
capable of but I'm just I'm very glad
and happy that it's here so that's
really exciting now up today we are just
taste tests that we've long promised we
are going to be tasting little seizures
Papa Jonathan's Pizza Hut and Domino's
the big four and we're gonna be we're
gonna be judging them on all metrics
possible find out what's the best pizza
we got we have the bachelor follow up
we're in we're gonna have a rose
ceremony we have five applicants who
have submitted videos ian is going to be
presenting a roast so just two of them
three girls will go home with their
hearts broken to pieces and we've got so
much more so much more fun fun times
ahead of us so let's get ahead I don't
want to get a food poisoning like I did
with all of our previous we've done two
previous food taste tests and I feel
like I've got food poisoning both of
those times so I mean obviously Pete
it's just a cheese pizza so it's not
exactly like Arby's roasted beef which
is already give it at a risk of food
poisoning once you let that thing sit
out boy no good but anyway I don't want
wait too long so let's do the pizza
taste test
we've got here's the different metrics
we've got delivery time dough sauce
cheese happiness value overall
experience and the diarrhoea of fat the
diarrhoea factor of course which we will
be reporting on later so it's kind of
what the heavy heart that I have to do
this without ela because it kind of
always made the Oh
you're here why are you in the CEO
outfit you like wearing it today um
you've been served
are you talking about where is this
legal papers why are you smiling
I shouldn't smile really it's pretty
serious either why are you smiling right
now is this a joke you come out here
after all of a fight and you can see I'm
served yeah I you know I own a business
now and I'm an independent woman and I
don't need no man we own a business well
yes but you have been doing all these
taste tests lately quest for divorce
yeah
what is this are you serious yeah we had
one fight ago like I have a couple of
taste tests you want a divorce you
should read it
on September 10th mr. Ethan Klein
ordered five pizzas under the guise of a
taste test he ate it despite knowing
that divorce was pending you're talking
about this yeah it's a little bit in the
future but it's part of the show I'm
doing how could you say that I'm doing
it for under the guise of a taste of
this is a good segment people like
watching me eat food dude they know I
don't know are they just being polite on
August 27th Ethan engaged in consuming
two chick-fil-a sandwiches and two
Popeyes sandwiches two of which were
labeled as spicy and sat out for hours
before consumption the result was a
disastrous diarrhea that caused pain and
suffering to plaintiff mrs. Ella Klein
in the form of smell of the toilet bowl
being painted like a Jackson Pollock the
lawyer that we do together I gave them
the information and they put in the
language on a on out of August 23rd
Ethan consumed three pounds of Arby's
roast beef
that's I think probably an exaggeration
three pounds we got it all on camera
three pounds of RV roast beef and
subsequently had three days of diarrhea
well that's not an exaggeration all
under the guise of a taste test I don't
know why you keep saying guys have a
taste does this people are watch this is
part of the show you let me how can you
put a says you take a bite and you're
done you take a bite you give you a
review look at all this you move on
freakin kidding me you want me to you
need me to you need you were gonna throw
it everything we've done this is just
your this is just everything you ate in
the last 30 days in consideration of
this ela Klein formally requested a
vorse effective immediately I'm not
signing that [ __ ] so which one is this
this is little seizures what kind of a
taste test is it you're just eating it I
just got some of them being such divorce
papers yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] eat some
please without you want you with me
don't since we're getting divorce might
as well taste out I'm thinking buy it
grab a little seizures all right here we
go
that was a good bet for anyone who were
you at home we are not getting divorced
and we just rolled the [ __ ] out right
here ah well you know you still love me
don't ya so actually we are doing a
taste test
he's really important content for us the
guys in back all have slices I don't
like it and so Little Caesars first of
all worth noting is Apple they don't
deliver cuz the [ __ ] is so cheap hmm the
pizza itself cost like 850
I shouldn't eat them I thought well I
don't have the information sucks to be
you
maybe I forgot a good boy let us are you
like it's like eight fifty for a cheese
pizza so the value is there they don't
deliver so at the post negative twenty
two bucks but if you're on foot little
seizures or fight for 850 not bad what
do you think of the dough the sauce the
cheese the heaviness the overall
experience and the diarrhea factor I
don't like the flavor of the tomato
sauce it feels cheap I think the kind
that I don't like it does feel cheap
mega doodoo and it does seem it seems
like has a high diarrhea factor yeah
look I would expect to have a a big what
was it was it a DD mega duty from this
dd- um so wait do you do you say that
overall you don't like it no I didn't
like it at all okay can I have that okay
can you hand me the press please come on
now the whole pie goes you got a lot
more pizza yeah save some room there's
room you guys think of the seizure yeah
I mean what you said is pretty accurate
it's you got bang for your buck it's
alright I think the Sun it tastes like
um like the marinara sauce they give you
with like mozzarella sticks like Oh
mm-hmm
it tastes like cafeteria pizza yeah yeah
like what you will get at school in fact
they probably buy little seizures it's
probably cost effective for them Zach
loves it right
yeah I hate the whole thing all right
Ian any thoughts you guys all have
slices I mean come on chime in what do I
got a bag but it's too thin it's very
lightweight there's not a lot of you
know 850 they used to be 5 bucks yeah
see that might be too much information I
don't think but at the point that you're
paying 850 you might as well get like a
quality pie
and with I mean post mates is unfair
honestly to read it but as 20 was the
base price right 850 was was if you went
in there and paid that's before taxi
you're walking out that pizza with ten
bucks dude hmm
not worth it so I don't know it's a
little sweet - it is yeah
now as you guys know I'm a fan of Papa
Papa's always in the house for me but
today they threw us a curveball you know
Papa John's the total including delivery
the delivery fees five bucks the pizza
was 16 it came out to a total of 23
bucks with tax and everything okay at
the door pizza look at this [ __ ]
I mean you guys know I've ordered a lot
of pizzas in my life they didn't slice
it they literally sent us an unlicensed
have you ever seen something cool drop
the ball on this what happened is they
got rid of Papa yeah what'd you get so
what happened with Shaq's in charge for
Shaq this is one slice I why do we need
to cut it let's do a taste test this is
[Laughter]
so much press now our people really
enjoying this or are they over it they
say they do they're probably thinking
like what okay we got it like why
another one already pizza say they like
it yeah I thought you didn't read
comments - oh you know I've reported I'm
I saw that they got lots of you see look
hmm
there's a huge area watching them to
like it
Cheers oh hi I'm Zack come pick up his
license very butter clicking the mouse
and Papa's in the house Papa John was
alive today he would be rolling in his
grave alive if it wasn't alive and then
this one what a great show now that's a
serving okay guys everyone enjoy take a
bite
experience will pop has to offer I have
to tell you you're really pushing it
Ethan I don't like divorce me well I am
trying
I dare you to find divorce a divorce
judge in this frickin country will
accept that
oh he eats too much does it divorce okay
he eats too much [ __ ] the drunk the
pizza toss in our entertainment job
divorce denied well say can I divorce it
judge for she'd have sex with me why cuz
you like I want to divorce but that's
funny I like the idea that you can force
people to stay together like danaiah
and you must sleep with them once a
month to consummate the marriage yeah I
know she's not tasting a pizza I took a
bite what did you think so it's better
than little seizures but it's not that
good it's too sweet it's tube ready it's
very sweet it's not good
I'm usually I'm big on Papa but I don't
like it
there's no [ __ ] slices dude I've
never ever seen this before ever when -
what's dead guys's review yeah I don't
find this to be see that's John's they
bring up the garlic sauce I've never had
the garlic sauce oh [ __ ] got me moving a
little sub-sect you can't see her face
boat hmm
this one's got me moving a little bit
who knew that once you melt butter on
something it's got me walking out of
here walking out of your life do you got
any mail okay you [ __ ] up somebody
bring me napkins oh yeah
I kind of feel like there's two ethan's
and if like now everyone gets to see
this is the thing I got fast food
enthused Ethan
yes you know and I need interesting you
like it like brings you alive you get
energy you're like me you're dancing
like if I say we're gonna get pizza
tonight all the science like the best
day ever
I'm doing breakdancing I'm doing the
worm across the house and chef it is
it's [ __ ] up you know why it is I
think it's like my parents didn't take
care of me as a kid and when they cooked
which was rare it was just awful
I didn't he out starve it was that bad
like my dad would buy like the [ __ ]
on sale steak that was three days
expired and like I mean it's inedible
also what they cooked my dad's favorite
dish to make is burnt onion pasta
remember he made that recently I've
heard about it I ever he burns Ryan's
and then just flavors the pasta with
burnt onions and butter it is you cannot
it's it's a horrid so so the best days
to me was when I got to eat food because
they would order a pizza or bring home
fast food cuz I was like oh I actually
like the taste of this and so I think it
calls back some kind of but don't you
feel like now you would be kind of
against it I hate I don't you when I
like rebel against well clearly not
clearly that's not the case but that's
what's so special about a podcast this
is Who I am as a person and if you think
I'm not gonna go back and take another
bite of that butter sauce and you don't
[ __ ] know me you got two more pizzas
though okay I'll get to those yeah well
I don't I thought I was honestly sorely
disappointed with the John's and I'm not
even there I'm not even including the
lack of [ __ ] sly slices
mega dudu we should call and complain I
mean that's ridiculous
I spent 22 [ __ ] hard-earned dollars
on that you know all right so next up
we've got classic classic classic as a
guest
Domon hoes you see what I did there
mmm-hmm dominoes dominoes actually is
the most expensive just came out to 31
box eye mask and ain't cheap hmm Ethan
the the pieces that you broke off for us
one of them has a giant bite taken out
of it was that you know wasn't me why
would I do that
single Zilla probably it's the lawyer
the lawyers sneaking around taking bites
yeah he's back here so a grant to this
piece is not fresh yeah but Pizza
connoisseur like me I can tell this
could of the three we've tasted it's
probably my favorite mm-hmm I think it's
got a good balance of cheese and sauce
and bribe it's got a rich it's got a
rich full flavor yeah but most expensive
31 bucks for a large pie cheese that's a
little pricey so there's a technicality
there they had a minimum delivery amount
oh hi everybody
so we had to get cheese sticks too which
is a [ __ ] stupid so was about the
same price but you had to order more
than just I had a bite Nathan Dan was
eating the LA so I was like Dan you
[ __ ] stop right now
give me half there was rage and your
house that bro excuse me
the qi6 were better than the pie those
chicks are unbelievable those were so
days overrated but we're not talking
look Leela how so we're looking at
Popeye and Domino's similar price range
was what we're looking at here so but I
gotta say I think Domino's is hitting it
on all cylinders I have to say little
seizures was so bad that there the value
to enjoyment is totally out of whack
like don't ya eat that and what was the
delivery time did you say Mike who
arrived first yeah I've got that here
so Pizza Hut which we're gonna be eating
now was here 25 minutes it was quick
dude Papa and Domino's actually arrived
at the same exact time they cross each
other in the hallway coming to the same
office I wonder if they thought they
were being trolled that was 45 minutes
big difference Little Caesars was 41 so
Pizza Hut which we're gonna try finally
came in with the resounding best
delivery time by far okay now if we're
looking at the cost of the pie we're
looking at $22 seventy two cents for the
$5 tip um let's just say I think I think
these these nice ones are all the same
you got Domino's you got Papa you got
pizza it's all the same okay so and it's
just scissors white looks so clean I
like the look at that cheese don't you
yeah okay so this is so here we go I
haven't had pizza heighten up and ages
mmm saucy hmm it's a nice sauce moment
there oh my good oh so this one's the
greasiest by far yeah this one's like so
I've got the most cheese too
it's like heavy on the trees oh go what
do you think it's pretty good I felt
it's between this one and Domino's
confess mm-hmm when the pizza arrives
you in here you were out getting
something from the house mmm arrived so
fast I had a slice fresh of course and I
was like this is the best [ __ ] pizza
I've had in a long time huh so I
actually wanted I think I think about in
my opinion a clear win the big shot
I think it's my favorite I delivered the
quickest st. prices all these other
[ __ ] it's just too expensive are you
there mm-hmm you're bright oh cheese and
sauce no wonder Papa John's a
billionaire there's [ __ ] flour dude
but I guess you can share it with a few
people so it's not one meal do people
really share pizzas I feel that most
people just do people not I feel like
people must usually just get like a 3x
I'll eat half of them and then eat the
rest like over the next couple weeks I
think actually not I think you're really
wrong about not one I love that one
what is your guys's experience just so
that it doesn't think that I'm insane
with what wait wait ordering here in
headlights what was it you like cut it
in and you're like panicked and looking
around like Danny went rogue and give
them Kim usually I go first I was but I
was chewing so it's like E and you go
for it's not right what am i doing right
all right come on get your [ __ ] together
what we so first question that I have
for you guys is in your experience when
you order pizza you share it with other
people right yeah I mean with what
Ethan's talking about I'll order
occasionally like a small or a medium No
and eat a few pieces and then save the
rest but if you you said double XL eat
hattery oh yeah that seems a bit much
can I tell you can i confide in you
something no I want to hear anymore it's
nothing to happen recent this was during
college when I was packing on a lot of
[ __ ] wave dude this is what I used to
do there was a piece of place in Santa
Cruz what was that peace place called by
Trader Joe's we used to like it
no no it's closed I heart but they had
really it was really expensive but it
was really good they had a buy one get
one free of any of any price it's that
place that has like cool murals on the
walls inside and everything that's the
catalyst okay they have $1 slices that
all the homeless people line up for as
they're like yeah huge and [ __ ] ass
load of calories no there's a difference
it's called like what wood fires or some
[ __ ] and I would order the pizza I'd say
I've got a buy one get one free coupon
of any size and I would get this look
like the [ __ ] biggest possible most
expensive piece of generally that would
be like the barbecue chicken or some
kind of Hawaiian special with bacon
three excel it was [ __ ] huge dude
like I'm telling you the size of all
four of those pizzas I'm the delivery
guy which I shop I'd be like I've got
dog I I totally can't find the coupon
because I know that they had the offer
but I didn't have the coupon thank God
and we used to do it so much me my
friends that by the end when it started
getting too awkward the delivery guy
would be like dude I didn't really need
the coupons like and he would call and
then though on the last time he called
his managers like you know this guy
doesn't have the COO
on he's like I got it I can only he
already had both he's like I can only
give you one pizza okay do you want you
were dated by yourself he said do you
want to still want to be like know us
dude those were trying times I needed a
pizza but he's like you know what just
take it and don't ever call us again but
you wouldn't buy that for yourself so I
would take yeah two of them two of them
you know it was wrong with you listen to
me I'm not dumb
thirty pizzas thirty dollars but you're
talking to [ __ ] monster super good
pizzas I would immediately put one in
the fridge that one's gonna last me a
week I will go upstairs peace moan maybe
like a quarter because I mean even a
[ __ ] glutton like me could only do a
quarter of a pizza that big and I would
I would probably have like thirty slices
of pizza in the fridge that I would
slowly eat over the course of a week or
two and I would dip it in ranch - bro
I had housemates I had a house in Santa
Cruz and I had four housemates that I
didn't know so I just was like in the
kitchen and then in my room that's it so
I would run up into the room with a with
ranch I know it just I would [ __ ]
beast mode it was just a bottle or ranch
that's the same house that I lost all
that weight into though because I I got
no disgusted for myself I remember I
took a picture with my housemates and
they posted on Facebook a tag dream back
when people use Facebook yeah and I saw
a picture of myself and I would like to
even recognize myself because I gotten
so [ __ ] fat funnily enough much
fatter than I am now no yeah really yeah
I thought you I thought you kept saying
that now you're at your fattest that's
what I'm saying I'm no I was shocked by
how fat I was yeah but now I'm
significantly fatter than I was but when
I saw that picture of myself that was
the moment I decided to go on that crazy
regimen which I lost like 50 pounds on
so a lot happen in that house did you
like my story no I wish I dunno
I liked your story and I wanted to let
you finish but we got to go to break all
right well throw it to break
the great bill burr is out with a new
comedy special on Netflix today
September 10th called paper tiger we've
got a little clip here to tease it for
you let's have a look meet to movement
white male priviledge hipsters
[Music]
I'm a my a spicy spicy show I wonder if
this is gonna be Chappelle asked
provocative I can't wait to watch it
it's out right now today if you're not
watching Netflix bill birnes special you
are literally basically for your dead
weight on this planet Earth you're not
living life to your full potential
we got headlights boarding on
apocalyptic in the news every day odds
are you could use a lot that's where
Netflix comes in with the all new
stand-up special paper tiger from the
comedian bill burr y'all known loved him
filmed at the Royal Albert Hall in
London bill delivers an all-new hour of
his hilariously honest and guy so let me
tell you what the copy reads here no
hold bars
I wonder what bill would say about this
copy no hold bars takes on me to
movement sex robots outrage culture and
mail feminism bill burst paper Tigers
now streaming only on Netflix where you
can also watch as other specials walk
your way out let it go I'm sorry you
feel that way and you people are on the
same that title makes me laugh and for
more check out Netflix as a joke on
Twitter and Instagram where you can get
all of your neck flicks comedy news and
a daily dose of funny guys let's all get
on Netflix today and watch that
mother-effing Dilber special thank you
to Netflix and Bill burr and to all you
out there for being so special
stitch fix is what you need to look and
feel great because let's face it us guys
don't have time to go out to the mall
and even if we did honestly that's the
last thing me and many of you would want
to do because shopping sucks you got to
go you try it on you got to look at it
it's hard to even find stuff you like
with stitch fix you take a survey you
tell them about your style your budget
what you like and all the sudden you're
getting a box hand-picked from a
personal stylist sent to your home and
here's the best part you try on the
pieces of clothing if you don't like it
you simply send it back shipping is free
both ways and you get a refund you don't
have to you only keep what you like guys
it's it's like having the dressing room
in your home
and having someone pick out the best
[ __ ] for you it is truly a revolution
guys we've all got our own style you
know and some of its bad and some of its
worse I happen to be one of the worst
ones possible but with a level help from
a stylist the touch of a beautiful woman
like my wife or the touch of a stylist
hear of stitch fix they're gonna make
you look and feel like your dick
deserves to be sucked but wash it first
that's my tip to you they won't give you
that tip wash your dick before you go on
a date that's like one-on-one guys
stitch fix is online personal styling
service that delivers your favorite
clothing brand right to your door you
get started at stitch fix com slash h3
answer questions choose accessories no
commitment required you only pay for
what you keep $20 styling fee is
automatically applied towards anything
you keep from your box guys come the
Frick off of it
you never have to think about looking
good again with stitch fix here for our
fans you can get started today at stitch
fix calm slash h3 you get an extra 25%
off when you keep everything in your box
okay that's epic
that's stitch fix calm slash h3 stitch
fix calms / h3 look good and save some
time save some energy stitch fix calm /h
Lee Gaby's
what up mom Naish Ethan is probably
stuck in the bathroom again as always I
wanted to ask what do you think about me
with goss's I'm curious these are my
real glasses but I actually never wear
them so let me know what you think in
the comments it's not like lucky it's
just like really D style you know let me
know what you think yes we aren't liven
well entertaining would be in question I
am doing something
Eggman's over yeah it all kind of tastes
like [ __ ]
thank you old but not because I hate
pizza you because it's old like if you
were to tasted that Pizza Hut fresh you
would have been like maybe if you were
to punch through the glass window and
[ __ ] you have to tell you that from
my memory of like main key that one that
I loved the most was Pizza Hut hmm
so maybe maybe it's still my favorite I
don't know it was our surprise man the
one that I used to always order as a kid
I don't know it's a local one Hungry
Howie's Hungry Howie's is national I
hope he's a [ __ ] like I got time to
research but I feel like [ __ ] that's
part of the cycle you go from the joy
the thrill of the pizza being there you
consume the pizza it's okay it's not as
good as you as you anticipated because
they anticipations everything and then
sets in the regret like any addiction I
would assume yeah except drugs heroines
bomb well until it goes away probably
yeah sure
but then you just take more
well guys that was fun we were moving
right along we've got the bachelor the
hotly anticipated sequel we in our first
round and when you ready come ahead and
join us and the first round we took
submissions from many many eligible
girls and we narrowed it down to about
15 and from those 15 even selected the
five that caught his eye the most we had
huh we had hundreds of submissions just
to be frank Ian that's got to make you
feel good right I feel the opposite of
good right now good it's a really I feel
really bad yeah I don't feel good I
don't feel good about what I did mm-hmm
how many did you eat I had all that all
for you finish each slice yeah that's my
guy well to be objective you know
reviewer the whole slice that's what I'm
saying thank you very much I'll take
those these are the roses from the
original okay you can see that they're
still lush and beautiful just like Ian's
love listen to sound these men under the
table what do you think what do you take
me for I was about to [ __ ] I got a
piece so bad really about the city on
the Gatsby and singing out the window
dude I'd love to be on the Gatsby
started with a hundred narrowed it down
to 15 narrowed it down to five now these
five have submitted for our viewing
pleasure video responses to pre-written
questions that Yin has posed for his
future wife let me read some of these
questions as they come up that's kanye
album to bring on a deserted island know
everyone who is the number one
spider-man and why you're referring to
actor I'm assuming yeah yeah you got
invited to a potluck
it's an acquaintance you met one time at
a bowling alley for a mutual friend the
acquaintance says the potluck will be a
modest gathering for about 10 to 15
people and they're making burgers
they work in finance and have a nice
3-bedroom condominium with their fiancee
Alice and the roommate mark why do they
have a roommate if they're in good
question if they're in finance you said
they have a I didn't say they're good at
finance hold on let me back up here you
that they work in finance and have a
nice 3-bedroom condominium but they have
a roommate mark yeah okay yeah I'm just
stating what's happening in this
situation yeah I mean you didn't write a
check okay that's strange that they do
that but that's what it is
mark is a vegan they have one cat named
Marcus the potluck is 45 minute drive
from your house you're asked to bring a
dessert what do you bring let me think
about this
it's an acquaintance you met one time at
a bowling alley from a mutual friend
and you're driving 45 minutes to a
potluck
I'm not going to this potluck is that an
acceptable answer that is an answer if
they're like I'm not [ __ ] bringing
anything because I'm not going in this
Marty would you find that a good answer
a bad answer I could see why that would
be a good answer you're interesting a
trick question
yeah potentially something to consider
yeah pizza time who do you were from and
what do you get well I don't be
listening closely to that answer here so
here was someone who needs to go to the
restroom do you a ridicule them be
shamed them those are kind of I think I
so bad what's the different ridicule and
shame like what does actress did is
ridicule what did he say
I got a piece about that that is
ridicule okay and shame shame is you've
got to go again why don't why do you
keep going knock it off
I see oh thank you interesting well you
like maybe you uh I'm not playing chess
I'm just trying to get into the mind of
eat like how many people are playing
chess er I've been playing chess I've
been playing checkers for years politely
allow them to excuse themselves in peace
like any normal decent human being so
that may I mean yeah I got Yatta Yatta
yes you yada-yada that would be shame
that would be ridiculed okay yeah
because that's the I mean it's a it's a
softball question
mm-hmm maybe they say ridicule we'll
find out let me read the whole thing
please allow them to excuse themselves
in peace like a normal decent human
being so that they may relieve
themselves without the shame over the
fact that they may go slightly more
often do you pee a lot is that what this
is about
I don't think I do then why is this such
a big part of your life that people are
ridiculing and constantly shaming you I
wonder I'm not quite sure he's so bad
why would that be interesting other than
people because they consume large
amounts of water or not just a can of
soda pop a day and give them the common
courtesy of doing what every person on
the planet does multiple times daily
without any sort of spectacle of fuss
strange strange question but is your
answer ok let's see what they say let's
fold I haven't seen any of these me
neither is exciting did you edit this
yourself no I didn't I'm in love this is
Dan's work best Connie album the kind of
on the I would bring it would either
have to be I think the college dropout
or My Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy
that fantasy I'm not too sure which one
I'd go cold depend on what damn getting
stranded what fives I'm feeling just
getting in touch my first what how do
you know that you didn't just name
random album cuz she seemed torn
anyone who gives me one answer that's a
little iffy because there is no true
answer that did seem genuine mm-hmm she
seemed and it's Raina
mm-hmm okay I like it Ashlyn akane album
is like i said my favorite is late
registration but i think i'd actually
picked My Beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy
to bring to a deserted island that is no
so good just because it has a lot of
variety and the artists featured in it
whoa that's a really bear Rick Ross John
Legend - you know jay-z
Elsa Pusha T dude she's a fan Nicki
Minaj so I think I'd go at that one just
because there's a lot of different
sounds in it a lot of different voices
wow that was a that was a that girl's a
fan of how I respect that answer yeah
it's a good answer you did her home now
would you tell us if there is a bad
answer are you gonna be polite well
because there for this question
there is no bad answer but what we're
looking at there's some that are better
that's a good she knew all the people on
that album that was real [ __ ] and I my
lay registration maybe my favorite album
but I would probably pick the same one
because the variation variation we'll
see you know the smart answer jesse
worship island has to be get sea ghosts
because here's a fun fact about me I've
only listened to and seven of them she
say she's listened to eight songs eight
songs in her whole life
what the [ __ ] what is the eighth song
where was she raised like she grow up I
don't see any evidence of like a joke
yeah I mean let me go back that eating
is all hers by the way not dance further
record mm-hmm where the [ __ ] the mouse
come on I can't find the goddamn mouth
but it's not moving you guys Oh
North East Side it's not moving Dan
no we got Mountain the mouse doesn't
work look what I'm doing I'm trying okay
here it's back and seven of them context
did you review that mean I really want
to know what the eighth song yeah I want
to know why how do you avoid hearing out
of songs your whole life that's that cat
no I was also very confused by this when
when I was editing all this the only
thing I could think of is maybe because
you can tell the english's are not our
first language maybe she just meant
she's only her
and fun yes that must be honestly how
can you not hear someone's laying over
here on hand you know bad head level so
you know so lean over and look what a
low-cut maybe your back is hurting her
you like the cleavage is that a good
point or a bad point for you in I was
like the god hands up in the back wall
that's what you noticed what do I notice
first this is how I record daily vlogs
and [ __ ] I gotta say I don't want to be
this nice good thank you go ahead if we
want this to be interesting yeah it's
gonna need to be some realness here I'm
being real and now you're not it stick I
got a piece so bad it's stick what this
you see how I hope that Jamie Ethan
that's real how about that is real how
about you guys compiled a bunch of sound
bytes
I'll leave my mouth closed and then you
could add in what you like that is how
it feels almost sin because you're not
being real with that man even did you
not notice her cleavage first don't and
just talk if you you need to tell me the
truth and the only true answer is yes so
just say yes if you had the eyeball
trackers painting okay
[ __ ] you're a liar bro what you have
the front I know you don't have the
front to kick it I know it and I'm more
vulnerable because I feel bad off Pizza
I'm being real okay now that you've seen
her cleavage I think she's a very edge
what have you you see that she's leaning
what are you referring to again this is
a problem I'm gonna kick him out a good
divorce would work divorced yeah more
papers on do it
not space meetings that's I didn't hear
what she said yeah okay I can't zoom
what if you do you want to try the mouse
I have them I'm just trying to show you
have one yeah Dan kid how do i zoom on
her cleavage I don't know man
went Windows and because usually I can
zoom on this one in a browser all right
well we got the idea what do you say to
eight heartbreak it awaits and
heartbreak she said no explanation
needed do we I mean I don't need an
explanation but I see that one's a
little that's that's his saddest album
and if I'm on a desert island I'm
already probably pretty depressed you
don't need that so what's compiling on
so it's a bad answer she didn't think
about it but album is really good I will
like it but overall for the deserted
island I don't know okay with that
answer
let me put let me say what can translate
for ya bad another thank you I'll be
your translate in other words bad
[ __ ] answer nice tits though right in
you I didn't rent your translators off a
little bit about what I say what do I
got here allora first question best
kenya album to bring on a deserted
island i to the unreleased yandi I'm not
a big Kanye fan but I have a friend who
listens to a lot of Kanye and he wants
to put that on and I thought it was
great Amir for something unreleased
has a lot of good I got a piece so bad
Lots
well she's referring to leaked illegal
content which we fight do not condone
and it's frowned upon right yes yes so
she pretty much she pretty much did
everything wrong she said I'm not a con
you've him and she referred to an
unreleased album yes Wow
but do you expect your future girlfriend
/ wife wife to be a Konya fan for sure
no no how is he ever gonna date an on
Kanye fan the guy cuz I feel like at
least she was being true and not acting
and like wait day I adore girls you
don't know I mean you could you could
open Wikipedia and say well this one has
a lot of collabs just saying a bold
choice that's just straight up be like
not a fan yeah I respect that okay I
think that's true okay listen I'm on
spider-man why we skip some of these
questions we've got two minutes in
there's nine minutes - I'm just - Gabe
we're dealing with your future wife and
you're telling me to hurry up I don't
understand this guy I seriously I don't
get it what we're doing here I'm trying
to find you true love and you're telling
me skip questions can I hold the roses
you sure you're good but be careful
they're really brittle fossilized oh you
only get to give out - you understand
okay got it
we could continue all right who are you
giving me a rose no I'm just separating
the roses to give stop I'll stop
yeah all right Rick Renee who's everyone
Rayna Rayna Rayna Rayna Rayna
challenging ma'am
probably just for me I was Mary Jane
with the redhead
that was my aunt she was my idol
and really can't beat an original but
Tom Holland just like killed it he I
think fits the character wait I thought
you liked Tom Holland an original but
then again he did I think such a great
job and he he really kills the role of
spotty I'm really nervous too Tom
Hollands up there Andrew Garfield is
count really but I have to give it to
Tony wire oh he's actually nerdy she she
I feel like she was charismatic Sam I
could just he perfectly blends the
confidence of spider-man there's some
pecan awkwardness of Peter Parker that's
good right this spider-man body so there
have been many very good spider-man's
[Music]
more slick Odin
wait Neil Patrick Harris is I'm afraid
that I came for this music so I'm sorry
[Music]
yeah he turns around he goes I'll get
you your rent when you fix this damn
door I got a piece so what's with the
spider-man I love it it's one of my
favorite comics not really I do I was a
kid but now this is the complicated part
look did you have a clear and
now on Oh from the spider-man Oh for
spider-man yeah well she was pretty she
hit the quote me I appreciate the quote
that's powerful you've been you pulled
it right out of it and the second what
does hurt at say Zach what does it say
she changed her standing position as
well so yeah maybe she was fixing the
camera there's nothing wrong with
working was what you got either I mean
you know I've seen you do it it looks
like smile and something smile mmm I
can't tell it's yeah we can't tell what
it says okay let's see what the potluck
this is it well the correct answer is
Tobey Maguire and it seems like to said
that what a potluck was I had a rough
idea but also I'm Australian sorry come
on give me a bit of a leeway anyway I've
taken all factors into consideration
besides the cat story cat you can't get
a dessert speaking of Australian I can
bring Ozzie desserts and speaking of
desserts Wow
I'm surprising myself I used to make
cakes for a living I had my own business
making and selling cake we go back so
you guys don't know about Ian's pasta
but he's a baker yeah he brings a lot of
delicious bakes in here this is a for
one's a doozy
ok I like I had some big oh ok girl
she's from Australia but I think we can
get her visa mm-hmm Oh Harris ok one on
d-day Bert you want to do a lemming
Tain's but also since you did mention
that the roommate was vegan I'd bring in
vegan desserts as well something that I
think would also be visually pleasing is
mini cheesecakes mini vegan cheesecakes
really nice is a 45-minute Drive I did
take that into consideration
everything's packed nicely with ice
blocks in a cooler back so everything
stays nice and cold
I was never fun well that's a really
thoughtful answer I really want someone
to say oh she's on that right because
she skipped over the part that you met
it's an acquaintance you met one time at
a bowling alley
like there's a lot but that's that's the
two sides yours is reasonable to say I'm
not going I'm out but if someone is
gonna go to that they gotta come
prepared
she seems like she would it he seems
prepared I was very impressed with their
baking I think that was something you
guys can really connect yeah yeah good
question in my entire life so so she
doesn't go that's what this kind of
anxiety that's a good one Ashlyn it's
just lemon bars my recipe for Lemon bars
is already vegan so mark would be able
to eat them okay plus they don't need to
be refrigerated or anything and they're
supposed to sit out and be room
temperature anyway so even though they'd
be pretty warm a little 45 minute drive
from my house to the potluck they'd be
just as good
plus I make really good lemon bars you
are what do you breathe I'd say I don't
know yeah but when I look at the
circumstances surrounding this
hypothetical anecdote and I take my
lifestyle into consideration I've come
up with the conclusion I bake my famous
apple tart and then I'd show up late
with only half the pie remaining and I'd
say that I got robbed along the way so
she eats the time she wants to show up
fashionably late and then but she wants
to keep half for herself mm-hmm it's an
interesting angle okay she oh she's
changing her position every time that's
kind of charming
mixing it up was that a [ __ ] coffee
grind like a coffee filter so we make
the brownie pizza it can be vegan it
doesn't taste gross and vegan so that's
good but this will make the vegan guys
feel special and he needs that cuz his
name is Marc he lives with a couple so
he's already third-wheeling and their
caps name is Marcus I like the cheese
respective marks really on the go and
simply I forgot the third part smile and
simply smile I got a piece so bad
weights down while always driving
probably hopefully not her boyfriend I
don't think so but you know sometimes
when you're in a relationship you're
like what if Brad Pitt wanted to [ __ ] me
would you be okay with that and my bread
pit no but that's my point they're like
you're that famous guy and he's like
yeah if if Brad Pitt will [ __ ] you I
won't be mad so maybe that's the
situates the case that's pretty sad your
pattern from the h3 funkiness no dude
you gotta accept that do you get
recognized a lot on the street not a lot
now and again some guy did it the gym
the other day and he was falling
it was a little he was following it like
he was he was like hey man and I was
like it's weird when you're in the gym
because you know not a social
environment don't want people looking at
you there you know what I'm dropping
weights on my head or something grow but
it doesn't happen that often what about
what about you Dan
what getting recognized yeah oh that
would require me to actually go out
we're like oh we don't leave the [ __ ]
house yeah yeah it's happened now and
again when I go to concerts is that fun
for you guys I don't mind it at a
concert that's a lot better than at a
gym for sure yeah yeah what about Zach
yeah I've been recognized that leaves
five times for act on campus or one
campus in college how does that feel is
it cool it's pretty cool some dude
wanted to take a picture with me what do
you you should have let you guys should
have like like a slogan you say when
someone says I like Zach's yours could
be like um party on keep shredding yeah
and then he was that can be male I want
to show the men tell me if it's clear
yeah yeah down a little bit yeah this is
my chair I got I got my leg right next
to my chair and then look at anything
alright yeah okay dawg baby I got man
spread em right on a man's bedroom it's
real
you can't man spread your wife who can
you I'm Ian when after you take the
photo don't say hi you should say
alright well I got to go pee so bad so
I'll see you later
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's really
funny but it's never gonna happen
what's your say well Dan say mine I
don't know it's like I'm was it not to
play devil's actually well actually I
got to go play devil's advocate
just to play devil's advocate person
honestly pizza time what do we order
well we know the real answer is pizza
well the real answer is round table so
on my last visit to America I had pizza
from dominos and it was life-changing
like maybe that's a bit of an
exaggeration so would get Domino's again
but maybe I would get someone to
surprise me with what to order I have a
hard time picking because I'm so
indecisive when it comes to something
like food which I love so much so I
would either have someone else choose
but some classics that I like you've got
your Hawaiian barbecue chicken is good
classic cheese you know whatever
whatever floats your boat
it's pizza unhappy no not picky first we
go to pizzas usually just a vegetarian
pizza a lot of vegetables on top maybe
some extra like feta cheese baked on top
of it as well that's good if I'm
ordering in a pizza it's gonna be from
Domino's I'm sorry
almost maybe like three times in my life
and every time I've gotten it they
always messed up my order
well they didn't slice ours I don't look
closely once if I can't give Papa John's
another chance so I don't have our date
with Domino's I'm sorry Jesse
[Laughter]
with cheese more cheese mushrooms
I'll just literally get cuz I'm basic as
hell
what did she faking it I mean I know
she's doing it good yeah we got it
she said margarita pizza I know she's
doing a goof with the make up I assume
that's not how she usually goes outside
right it seems like maybe she does like
a makeup Channel or yeah we sort of lost
like the context but she explained at
the beginning she was just gonna
multitask this is her actual makeup she
goes outside in no she said his drag
makeup okay yeah that makes sense I was
gonna say that I thought she looked I
thought she looked great in the
beginning
you're not on board with these lashes
he's a good boy
well I mean it looks very dramatic I
would assume it's not she doesn't just
do it on a day to day that's probably
been going somewhere yeah would you wear
that would you put on lashes like that
oh me I'm the most special of occasion
only the most public wedding wedding no
I'll just literally get Pizza Margherita
because I'm basic as hell Barker is
basic I love the money and I hate
Domino's oh because they're pizza tastes
like cardboard
you get that so where am I going and
what am I getting I'm definitely going
to this place called piehole we have in
Boise is so cool that's like cool
graffiti on the walls it's just like an
awesome place it's really cheap too but
they have this potato bacon pizza so
it's a creamy potato bacon I got a piece
okay now some weird question about weird
question [ __ ] strange this whole
question about paying a B and C as you
are possible options
I went rated out because it would be so
long I want to rub this up as quick as
possible so I'm not boring you guys but
see see all away thank you
because like Ian sometimes I need a
piece so bad and it sucks cuz you know
you just can't help it and sometimes
you're doing something really busy like
working on a really important webcast I
know but you just really need a piece
iPad weird because if you really look
into it it's it's about your cause Ian
because you're bringing awareness to do
to the people that you're very welcome
just thank you I don't understand what's
all this hubbub about in golf you need
you know I drink at least 2 liters of
water every single day and I try to be
extra sure of it
and you know keep myself hydrated you
love to have some clear pee in this
household that is a good factor I would
personally never say I have to pee so
bad in front of thousands of people so
well girls really put a good they all
really stepped up to the challenge
don't you're all winners in my eyes so
in two roses to present we have five
lovely girls but only two roses this is
difficult so we've got those are all to
summarise we have rain up we have Raina
Raina and I'm Australia Ashlyn
Jessie we have Jessie we have Laura
Laura and Katy and we have where's Katy
Katy Rayna Ashlyn
Laura here let me pull up their pics for
you
go ahead think of Haiti and that's a sh
and we're missing one here on the on the
leg it's in the top it's the tech okay
whatever you come on again
okay who gets a crusty old rotten rose
so by the way now Ian's gonna give two
roses and we're gonna have to come down
to a final and the winner is gonna get a
plane ticket out here to Los Angeles to
go on a romantic date possibly even a
getaway possibly waffle tea like maybe
you guys can go to San Diego for a
weekend or something oh and we can like
hear about it I mean this is Syria this
is not a joke okay I'm looking for
sweets fantasy sweet baby
you guys are gonna [ __ ] know what the
coitus is not required what coitus okay
you hit a little accident on that coitus
coitus baby yeah but but this there's a
lot on the line for these these
wonderful young ladies so Ian do you
have any thoughts well uh I liked why
don't we go one by one like okay put up
Raina on the screen Raina Raina was
great I love that she baked sure that's
my bladder yeah she took into account
the traveling for the people the potluck
and I think I gotta give Raina rose
really I think so here we go again
marina
oh god I hate this part uh Reena
you got to put an accent on she's
estrella you'll see in yeah yeah yeah
might yeah oh my that was great will you
accept this dead decrepit rose
yeah with all my heart with all the
appreciation and sincerity in the world
I accept this rose
yes Truman x10 says long I just want you
to know that I I don't believe in
waiting you tell me I first have sex no
I don't believe that you we should have
sex before we get married
oh you mean coitus coitus yes I also
believe that I am um I am a
Scientologist so I hope that you'll be
able to join with me also I want to say
that I have a condition where my
butthole is so tight and I poop out of
my vagina all those in spirit of mine I
would love to accept your rose thank you
can I have a kiss not right now okay oh
that's exciting right up Wow
okay so we only have one row so you
better choose wisely now Tim okay Katy
and all her glory
Katy was grouchy
I liked Katie a lot yeah great girl I
like that she tested she drove around
with the she she put a whack yes yep
mobile absolutely uh she won't ridicule
my bathroom visitations okay I feel well
I mean I know it's right out there gay I
think I got to give Katy the other roads
the show there's a note to Ashlyn see
this is the part he did ridicule you
kind of she goofed on you a little bit
for saying who would say I got a piece
so bad in Friends of million people she
did goof on me exactly who doesn't
appear to be American although commute
she had an accident did she I don't
think three of them are from yesterday
that makes me question this since there
there they are far away like damn I live
in [ __ ] Australia you know where is
Katie that's the low right now low risk
reward she was the one that said she's
from Idaho right so yeah that she liked
the potato pizza that's right she picked
local pizza I think that's good I like
that too
so I Ashland's the one you chose no
Katie I didn't mean to skip straight to
her all right well whatever we know the
answers it's Katie we're come on oh
we're great they were all fantastic I
want to say Ashlyn you're safe you're
that girl yeah I wish you to poke fun
love and and you deserve love and you're
yes mr. right is out there Jesse
hilarious you are gonna find mr. Rosell
kills work and Frank and I want to know
what the let the 8th song was that she's
heard yeah Jesse I think you're too good
for in any lie I'm inclined to agree
Katie Katie you accepted yes and there
is no wonder why come on man she's got
great paintings on her wall great
artwork and then Laura all right who
Laura
I liked Laurie a lot too yeah Laura
seems like she's got a lot of character
a lot of personality but ultimately Ian
thinks that you are just not good enough
that's not translated and sure he said
no an emphatic no it wasn't in Phatak it
was very quiet so hesitant no on behalf
of Katie would you like to present a
rose to me I guess I have to right
Katie Catherine will you explain a lot
Catherine okay we don't have to fight
during the rose ceremony here don't make
words in my mouth okay well I've got
this really dying dead rose here will
you take it will you accept it will you
have it will you embrace this rose well
I do wish that you had a why is it that
you're presenting me with dead rose and
I mean that's not a romantic way to
start off our relationship but it's an
aged rose oh well - fine wine I would
like to say that I will accept this Rose
begrudgingly mm-hmm I think as a man you
have a lot of room for improvement yes
but I think that if we work on you if we
can get you up to - so where I think you
need to be is a as a man that we do have
a future
again well I'd like to know in yes first
of all yeah I don't have a job and I
don't like to work okay will you provide
for me I mean as long as I have one but
you know we'll see how that goes back to
the segment okay good you'll provide for
me and I also want to say that I don't
like having sex and I'll saw my lesbian
oh wow
so um I mean I have a bit of an
effeminate personality so so I'm gonna
need you to tuck your dick behind your
legs tape it to your [ __ ] and pretend
the yellow vagina when we have sex was
that okay with you
oh it's taped right now okay T Holly you
don't your pubic books of a sin you have
a vagina is that okay eat up this he
looked at that one thank you accepted I
was worried she wasn't cold nervous -
then she did so we've got Katie kind of
a hurtful speech from Katie oh no she's
making her a choice and Reina
did I finally say her name right yeah
so we're gonna have to reach out to them
for the final rose ceremony and the
winner wins a flight out to Los Angeles
and a date a romantic date within we're
gonna have to set up a romantic table
and like have some kind of obviously
well you guys have some a long time but
the vast majority we're gonna be
recording oh and I think if I get you
guys a hotel room on wanna put cameras
in it they do that in the bathroom
cameras in there all day yeah that is
true
well thank you everybody that was great
I pretty much know graduations to the
two finalists so thank you Bob
Visionnaire love really truly is in the
area romantic thank you in now you can
take that garbage and throw it out and
take these two these are the important
to keep these in the fridge yeah yeah
those are back in the fridge obviously
for safekeeping
gotta keep them fresh as possible so we
send them to Dave & Buster's for the
night David Buster's honey Haven buses
is fun I don't want my I think that's a
good date I came out during this podcast
I'm gonna check my phone really fast
because there's some big news I'm
checking professional oh yeah it's very
professional and I'm on my phone I'll
give a [ __ ] goddamn [ __ ] mother's
records this is like deep in nobody
watch this [ __ ] am i right if anybody's
watching this go to the comments and
type nobodies go to the comments and say
dick tape to my [ __ ] eat my pubic
bush out like I'm a woman either will
you perform that sex acts on me as an
act of love I'm already doing way
already divorced we had those papers
that I brought in yeah if I shave my
pubes and put my dick back it'll be like
eating out a woman so if you have any
female oriented fantasies you better get
it out with me now cuz I'm kind of into
it you are you could into the taping
yeah [ __ ] hot I get to I get to
participate in lesbian sex
[Laughter]
that's the whole [ __ ] show no we have
to get a [ __ ] but honestly that's
evergreen I'm over I'm done right how
long we done Dan about an hour and a
half so we're pretty good well that's an
episode folks SEO truly we've got the
Guinness World Records segment there's
gonna be a lot of fun we've got the I've
got this whole segment about how media
keeps [ __ ] over Andrew yang it's
pretty amazing but again it's kind of
evergreen too so save that we've got a
huge guests on Friday but I don't want
to give it away
mm-hmm I think it's better if it's a
surprise but need but just suffice to
say we have a huge guest on Friday that
I think a lot of people are gonna be
very happy to see is there anything I
can say that doesn't give it away it all
but hype sit up Dan nope yes leave it at
that but definitely tune in Bret it's
exciting I mean everyone is gonna be I
think not only happy but shocked to see
this person and they are they're a mega
celebrity this isn't like some meme [ __ ]
like this is a this is a mega slippery
you know it's OJ Simpson that'd be
[ __ ] epic no not you Simpson no it's
everybody it's someone everybody knows
and loves so Friday mystery guest it's
gonna be great all right you're gonna
screw it on out of here I wish I'm not
gonna guy I can't you know Hardy doesn't
get that thing in-n-out man nothing's
here to stay
I'm excited the Gatsby's here man yeah
fantastic well
happy Tuesday my dudes will see on
Friday first for a super special app of
the h3
bro cast
and girls broke cast broke cast maybe I
got a piece because I'm broke or like
broke as a person thank god this pizza
[ __ ] spell I regret everything you
say that what we're doing a bit it's for
the plug it's for the love of the game
nope alright let's do let's wrap it up
guys you see on Friday first super
exciting Megas special mystery guest and
next week just a small reminder that we
you will do Tuesday but then Friday
won't be in New York we need to announce
it more yeah I know you get the word out
September 20th pop up in New York City
in Manhattan do we have the address
I don't oh we don't be address yet or
maybe it's not it will be Inman well
just stay tuned check our social media
check our Chetty fresh social media
we're going down to - it's gonna be
funny
it's gonna be crazy it's gonna be super
fun the pop-up store is gonna be amazing
you seem really hyped about it oh I'm
tired I am high we are no I'm going in
New York for chrissake we're hyped and
nervous cuz we're gonna be flying with
you we'll be in New York City
alright guys we'll see you on Friday
Tata have a great week and carry on with
all the Lovings and God blessings in the
world I remember it's Pizza time
it's Pizza Huts time because they are
the clear winners and definitely
Pappajohn sucks [ __ ] around and little
seizures is honestly not that good
either so that's it goodbye
see Fredrik
[Music]